c'est que vous expliquez Xavier du pont
de ligonè aurait pu se rendre en bateau
jusqu'au Mexique et ainsi accéder au
Texas vous évoquez une information
donnée justement par Bruno euh c'est ça
c'est vous qui avez donné cette
information Bruno c'est c'est quoi
l'information non mais parce que moi
j'ai tjours été persuadé un qu'il était
vivant et deux qui vit aux États-Unis
parce que c'est un pays qu' connaissait
très bien il a fait 30 voyages avec
Michel Retif avec Emmanuel tenur donc il
connaissait à peu près tous les moyens
d'y aller et je pense que quand la
question de sa fuite s'est posée il
s'est dit euh soit je passe par le
Canada soit je prends moi je pense aussi
un cargo tu sais à partir de à partir de
la Hollande et puis aussi par le par le
sud par le le le Brésil ou enfin et à
l'époque il y avait pas le contrôle de
passeport VO maritime est beaucoup moins
sécurisé et à l'époque encore plus que
la voie aérienne donc selon vous du pont
de ligonis onit rencontré une
propriétaire de ranch appelé mind et
ligonis il avait passé des jours heureux
tellement heureux qu'il aurait souhaité
terminer sa vie la phrase valer le
détour ça c'est ce que c'est ce que dit
Bruno justement exactement je je cite sa
phrase dans dans mon roman euh
effectivement c'est l'une des pistes les
plus plausibles parce que vous savez les
fugitifs quand ils partent en cavale euh
et bien ils vont généralement chez une
ex-ptite amie qui peut leur fournir un
logement qui peut leur fournir euh euh
l'isolement euh l'argent la nourriture
sans qu'ils aient à sortir le truc c'est
que le fugitif pendant plusieurs années
il doit rester tranquille il peut plus
rien faire donc là on a vraiment
quelqu'un qui peut aller aux États-Unis
qui peut rester dans ce ranch de chèvre
hein c'est vraiment un élevage de chèvre
qui est à à au Texas à alpine euh les
États-Unis faut dire qu'il se fout
royalement de ce qui se passe en France
donc aucune idée et puis en plus vous
êtes vraiment isolé donc il peut rester
là-bas très tranquillement il a
quelqu'un qui peut subvenir à ses
besoins voilà donc ça ça a pas été ça a
pas été fait la coopération
internationale est très compliquée on
n'est pas dans les série Netflix où les
flic se déplacentte cour vous dites tout
pour vous c'est impossible qu'il qu'il
se soit suicidé derrière ah oui alors ça
ça alors justement pour ne
téléspectateurs parce que ça c'est
c'était ça vous dites que c'est
impossible pourquoi ouais alors
impossible attention on est jamais sur
de rien à 100 d'accord ouais mais déjà
les les premiers jours à Nantes avant sa
fuite tout est fait chaque jour
c'est-à-dire qu'il reste 6 ou 7 jours en
faisant des des en mettant des actions
qui visent la disparition c'est-à-dire
qu' il ne veut pas qu'on retrouve les
corps il est persuadé qu'on ne les
retrouvera pas c'est pour ça qu'il ne
prend aucune précaution quand il descend
de Nantes à Rock brune ces histoires
complotises qu'on entend oui il se fait
bien voir des caméras oui il dépense
bien de l'argent avec la carte bleue
pour qu'on voit qu'il est passé par là
non ça c'est du cinéma dans la vraie vie
les qui font ça c'est qu'ils ont aucune
idée il faut savoir qu'on est en 2011
faut pas juger les choses à postériorie
à cette époque là on n' pas idée de tout
de toutes ces choseslà maintenant on
sait qu'il faut pas se balader avec le
téléphone portable parce qu'on est
géolocalisé voilà maintenant on sait
beaucoup de choses à l'époque non donc
en fait il ne pense pas qu'on va
retrouver les corps et il a tout fait
pour euh je vais pas revenir sur les
détails de comment il a mis les dalles
enfin la Chau viive et cetera il pouvez
nous le dire he justement en fait bah la
Chau viive hein qui qui permet le
retardementaction des odeurs et tout ça
des chappes de de béton voilà vraiment
clôturer ça pour qu'on qu'on retrouve
pas les corps et puis ensuite vous avez
et bien ce travail méthodique tous les
jours qui est de d'enlever la boîte aux
lettres pour qu'il n'it pas de courrier
qui s'empile donc les voisins ne vont
pas voir qu'ici ne ne vit plus personne
euh il y a il a il a tout lavé il a il
s'est défait du matériel informatique il
a résilié le bail il a vidé le logement
étudiant de son enfant bon vous faites
ça quand vous allez vous tirer une balle
et puis la lettre les pèes de la lettre
la lettrere la lettre où il dit qu'on
est exciltr au FBI par pour ceux qui
connaissent un minimum la police c'est
n'importe quo raconter histoire de parce
que tout le monde n'a pas cet élément ah
bah il dit qu'il est qu' fait partie
d'un qui fait partie d'un plan de
protection de de victime de témoins qui
est par la par la DEA qui est en fait
les stup on va dire américains et qu'il
bénéficie de ce plan là et donc on on
l'exfiltre hein c'estàdire que Xav pones
travaille pour les stupes Américains bon
déjà ch
assez incroyable les Américains prennent
pas des Français pour faire du stup en
France ils s'en foutent
carrément ça tient pas
debout l'hypothèse du suicide elle est
pratiquement non non et puis en plus les
systèmes de protection vous savez aux
États-Unis ils ont été inventés pour
protéger ça a été fait pour la mafia
c'était le WS ça a été fait pour
protéger les mafiosos qui allaient
témoigner contre leurs anciens copains
donc en fait 99 % des gens qui sont sous
cette protection là sont des grands
criminels en fait américain ligonz
n'était pas un grand criminel alors vous
dites aussi il aurait fallu rechercher
l'arme du crime on connaî l'histoire
dans votre livre vous amettez
l'hypothète l'hypothèse qu'il soit allé
dans la forêt de robrune pour faire
disparaître son arme et non son corps
comme les enquêteurs pensaient puisque
il pens les enquêteurs on ont dit au
départ qu'il avait été dans la forêt de
rock brun justement pour mettre fin à
ses jours bon alors vous partez du
principe qu'il va pas du tout suicider
hein il y a aucun comportement
suicidaire nous expliqué depuis tout à
l'heure ou avec voilà il effectivement
on le voit disparaître le dernier
témoignage qu'on a c'est d'une personne
qui le voit sur la route des Châ ier qui
est à quelques mètres du parking du
Formule 1 et qui voit un homme avec une
housse à costume vestimentairement c'est
bien lui et il rentre dans la forêt et
alors là mais oui qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire dans la forêt bah pour moi il y a
qu'une il y a qu'une seule solution il
s'est débarrassé de tout de tout ce qu'
avait dans sa vie les mail les
ordinateurs les machins la voiture il
vient de l'abandonner sur le sur le
parking du Formule 1 qu'est-ce qui lui
reste le truc qui est le plus
discriminatooire pour lui c'est le fusil
en fait c'est l'arme du crime il peut
pas s'en débarrasser en zone urbaine
vous mettez ça dans une poubelle euh
dans dans 5 minutes il y a quelqu'un qui
passe par là qui ouvre la poubelle qui
trouve un fusil avec un silencieux s'il
a pas eu le s'il l'a pas enlevé euh il
va tout de suite à la gendarmerie parce
qu'il veut pas être pris avec un fusil
tout de suite on se dit c'est quoi ce
fusil ah il a tiré tiens machin on
découvre les corps le 21 bon paf ça
match exactement donc il ne peut pas
s'en débarrasser s'il est un minimum
intelligent et Bruno peut nous le
confirmer il est quand même intelligent
très intelligent très intelligent trs
intelligentou donc il peut s'en
débarrasser qu'en zone euh non urbaine
c'est justement le cas à Roque brune
vous allez et qu'est-ce que vous avez au
bout de ce chemin c'està direire la
forêt j étaé vous avez quoi vous avez un
lac vous avez un petit lac donc en fait
moi je pense qu'il y a eu un truc là
quand on a cherché un corps qu'on a
dépensé des effectifs incroyable de
police police judiciaire gendarmerie
spéléologue secouriste et cetera
hélicoptère avec caméra thermique mais
non il fallait pas chercher un corps il
est pas parti se suicider là il fallait
chercher un fusil ou il a dû la démonter
hein la carabine et jeté des pièces
ouais oui et s'en débarrasse dans le lac
alors quand j éta la démonté voou la
carabine et puis jeté voilà c'est assez
amusant parce que dans le livre qui est
aussi une fiction vous avez la partie de
mon enquête avec la fic et je suis allé
là-bas et le lac vous avez toute mon
hypothèse qui jette dans le lac qui
regarde le le fusil qui s'écoule tout ça
euh et puis je vais là-bas je vais
romiss sur Agence et le lac est asséché
mais bon ça c'était plus tard à l'époque
en 2011 il était encore il y av encore
de l'eau mais c'est assez amusant il y a
beaucoup d'autodérision dans mon roman
je me moque attention je dis pas
regardez c'est moi le super flic dire
vous AZ rien compris él qu'onait pas et
qui sont très importants qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire de trouple de
troupe oui de trouple on parle voilà
qu'il sa
femme ah oui oui oui jamais entendu
trouple
d'cord
effectivement raconter mais ils étai oui
ils étaient ensemble Michel re parce
qu'on parit de son meilleur ami donc on
parlait de lui a un instant c'est fou
parce que c'est quand même un élément
important donc en fait c'est quoi
l'histoire est-ce vous pouvez nous
raconter l'histoire depuis le début
c'està-dire que son meilleur ami c'est
Michel Retif parle apparemment il se
rend compte que sa femme le trompe avec
lui ouais c'est ça il reste quand même
meilleur ami bah oui il veut pas
divorcer parce qu'il veut il a pas
d'argent il veut pas payer une pension
alimentaire donc pour lui la meilleure
solution c'est de pour reconquérir sa
femme c'est d'accepter le fait qu'elle a
un amant qui est Michel Retif et de
faire des plans à TR et donc ça c'est
vraiment incroyable pour moi c'est le
fond du fond quoi moi aussi je pense
c'est c'est quand même un élément très
important et après après il est resté
ami donc avec Michel re puisquon sait
que c'est la dernière personne qui est
au téléphone c'est la dernière personne
qui l'a peut-être croisé ce que vous
dites et donc il y a cette histoire donc
il il faisit un couple à TR ou ou ouais
bah oui qui a duré un an et puis puis
après ils se sont lassés quoi il y a des
lettres qui en la tête table Excel
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit ces lettes c'est
bon
bah la plus connue elle a été diffusée
sur Internet elle dit salut les cochon
c'est c'est du P ligonis qui parle ouais
je ne vous pardonnerai jamais vous
m'avez trahi et mais il pouvait pas ni
divorcer ni quitter àè c'est ça le
problème et puis il voulait pas se
fâcher avec Michel hein d' d'où ça d'où
ça décision en fait parce que vous vous
en parlez tous les deux comme si de rien
n était mais les téléspectateurs là à
21h8 ils se disent qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette histoire mine de rien parce
que c'est quand même un élément très
important et puis surtout un homme qui
s'est suicidé en plus exement un homme
qui s suicidé derrière bon qui était mal
qui était malade hein après mais mais le
truc c'est que cette histoire de trouple
c'est ce serait quoi le motif le motif
le motif de de quoi exactement de cette
tuie du trouple ah non
d'accord ah ben vous avez un homme qui
est complètement qui qui est acculé par
les dettes hein ça il est endetté toute
part il a pris de l'argent à tout le
monde bon Bruno tu disais que il rendait
l'argent mais je pense qu'il en rendre
beaucoup là bah oui il AV à peu près 100
120000 € de dette enfin entre guillemets
tu sais c'est pas c'est une famille il y
a quand même des biens il y a quand même
des cousins il y a des gens qui ont de
l'argent il avait une tente qui était
assez riche enfin c'était pas la fin du
monde il était pas obligé d'en arriver
là c'est ça
le
donc sa femme au niveau couple bon ça ça
ça va plus les enfants apparemment il
les voit plus comme une charge que comme
non comme comme un coup un coupt ajouté
à la vie à tout à tout cet argent puis à
un moment donné bah qu'est-ce qu'on fait
alors il y a beaucoup de gens qu'est-ce
qu'ils font il ils suicident
euxmêm dans le livre je dis il a préféré
suicider entre guillemets les autres qui
est une autre solution euh et donc il a
tué tout le monde pour effacer ce passé
les les gens normaux entre guillemets
divorcent se séparent pour lui
apparemment c'était pas une option parce
qu'il y a toujours peut-être le regard
de l'autre personne qui vous juge de la
personne que vous avez aimé et qui est
là les enfants sont là donc il a préféré
éliminer cette veel il a recommencé
ailleurs alors les téléspectateurs
demandent beaucoup est-ce qu'il est
vivant pour vous vous avez du pont de
Ligones et vous Bruno vous dites que des
notaires nantés l'ont vu aux
États-Unis en fait oui de tous les
témoignages qui qui me sont parvenus voà
il y a beaucoup de de de témoignages
bidon des photos qui ne correspondent
pas à Xavier la la seule P qui est venu
à moi de quelqu'un de cette famille donc
c'est une famille de Nantes plutôt
catholique plutôt à droite de notaire
qui avait deux maisons à pornque et
quand Xavier arrive dans les années 2000
avant d'aller la Nant il habite pornique
et donc il loue une maison à cette
famille donc tous les mois il payer son
loyer parfois en cage donc cette femme
qui s'appelait Catherine le connaissait
très très bien Xavier le connaissait
même par cœur donc on est dans les
années 2000 en 2011 il y a les crime et
en 2015 cette famille donc décide
d'aller à San Francisco puisque le le
fils estîné qui s'appelle Charles Axel
travaille pour ubert et ils sont toute
la famille réunies ils sont dans le
quartier français de San Francisco et un
momentam cette Catherine va acheter des
pâtisseries et là il y a un homme qui
est devant elle qui qui attend dans la
queue un moment elle le bouscule sans
faire exprès il se retourne et là c'est
ce qu'on m'a raconté hein elle se
retrouve né année avec Xavier donc elle
le reconnaît tout de suite lui recule
fait des yeux hallucinés et part en
courant fin de l'histoire ah ouais elle
elle retrouve sa famille elle dit vous
savez qui qui qui j'ai vu j'ai vu Xavier
alors tout le monde se marque on pense
que c'est mais c'est des gens qui
rigolent pas qui plaisantent pas donc
sur place à San Francisco c'est pas la
peine d'aller voir les les policiers
américains ils sont foot et puis ils se
sont posés la question de se dire quand
on rentre à Nant est-ce qu'on va voir la
police ou la gendarme mais les gendarmes
auraient dit ah bon vous êtes la 50e
personne ce mois-ci qui me dit que vous
avez vu que vous AZ vous avez des photos
vous avez une preuve et en plus ils
étaient malins ils voulent surtout pas
être embêté par les journalistes si
jamais on donne corps à cette histoire
et donc ils n'en ont jamais parlé c'est
resté en cercle familial on a appris ça
en 2022 là oui il y a pas longtemps
alors ça s'est passé en 2015 on peut
plus rien faire il y a toujours une
enquête où l'enquête elle est au point
mort c'est un C case est-ce que alors
oui vous savez quand il y a pas de
nouvelle piste là vraiment une piste
fraîche à exploiter qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse il il y a rien à
faire on attend on attend qu'il commette
une erreur on attend une identification
de quelqu'un qui soit avéré on attend un
passage à aéroport bon il faudrait qu'il
soit vraiment ça fait combien de temps
là ça fait donc depuis 2011 201 1 est-ce
qu'il existe une prescription 13 ans euh
oui une prescription pour les pour les
pour les
meurtres mais
là est-ce estce estce pens qu' il a
modifié son visage ou pas du tout non il
rest mê c'est pas dans sa culture il a
pas besoinav il a un visage il pe enfin
nous on a fait des travaux sur son son
visage on a vieilli on a mis une barbe
on a mis les cheveux courts chauves en
fait il passe partout Xavier il passe
partout il a pas besoin de ça puis je
pense qu'il est il est assez malin à ses
manipulateurs pour séduire une famille
et au quel cas si un jour cette famille
dis donc tu ressembles beaucoup à
quelqu'un qui a tué sa famille oui
c'était moi mais ils ont tué toute ma
famille si je reviens en France ils vont
me tuer enfin tu vois il est tout à fait
capable trou un moyen de mais bon mais
en tout cas oui on est d'accord ça c'est
assez romanesque he l'histoire de la de
de la chirurgie esthétique on voit très
peu ça en vrai hein on voit ça dans les
films mais dans la réalité les fugitif
pu il a 63 ans aujourd'hui donc il a 63
ans aujourd'huiouis on le voit partout
donc il a pas besoin de faire la
chirurgie esthétique la personne qui l'a
vu à San Francisco elle a noté qu'il
avait changé de visage ou pas du tout
écoute le problème cette femme elle est
morte d'un cancer il y a 3 4 ans et oui
enfin elle l' reconnu tu sais elle le
connaissait elle le connaissait très
bien donc elle a vu son visage c'est
pour elle c'éit Xavier tu vois pourquoi
ils onent inventé ça franchement c'est
incroyable merci Bruno et merci Romain
Puertolas comment j'ai retrouvé Xavier
du P deigon merci d'avoir été avec nous